it is a chilling sight a mass grave rows
of coffins as burials quadruple in New
York this is Hart island where the
bodies of those with no known family are
temporarily interred some simply unable
to pay for a funeral on the seven-line
more signs of the cruel and equity of
covert 19 many of the passengers are
black and Hispanic new data suggests
they're twice as likely to die from the
virus than white people these are most
communities that are impoverished have
poor health care access
it was the pre-existing health
disparities made them more vulnerable
and then also their jobs are exposed and
to the to the public and to being sick
everybody calls us the frontline but
we're really we're the last one captain
AJ briones says he's responding to calls
from every age every ethnicity in
Yonkers but he does think space and
money are playing a role too you're
looking at poorer areas where the four
areas you know you have a lot of people
in a small and a small environment
versus say you know you live in a
suburban neighborhood it's you and your
family in your home and that's it then
comes a cool 303 or C respond
these days AJ is often the first at the
scene 3 Larry talent in New York State
17% of those who die from coronavirus
are black
despite representing only 9% of the
population this patient is from another
heavily effected group she's struggling
to breathe so they're taking her to
hospital she's also Hispanic and it is
the Hispanic community in New York City
which has the highest death rate around
Tobit 90 new patients a few miles away
an exhausted frontline unites but
they've seen disparity to anybody who
has what we call comorbid disease
diabetes hypertension heart disease
anything like that is more susceptible
to this disease and it tends to be more
lethal so in that population we often
know that there's a fairly high
prevalence of diabetes and heart disease
in America there are no daily figures on
race and ethnicity in this pandemic yet
without them it will be harder to focus
resources and ultimately save lives
Cordelia Lynch Sky News New York